[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
today was a rainy day i went to
speaker's corner i just finished my
speaker's corner and i was heading home
i got a message
showing me a despicable uh a disgusting
act from a group of palestinian
supporters
and here is what happened brother
sisters and i was so enraged
i came to south london to pick up my
daughter um and i
um drove past brother zeeshan and i said
to him bro
i'm tired i'm exhausted it's been
raining i'm like
wet and so paranoid i said bro and and
he didn't answer his call because he was
busy recording
but i had to throw a little pebble to
his window and scare him
so he can open the door and i said bro
we need to do this video and brother and
sisters people think we enjoy them as
well
it takes our time family time but it's
so important the reason i'm doing this
video is because it's disturbing and i
know it's going to be hijacked to change
the um the narrative so here's the video
let's watch it for ourselves
a group of absolute idiots if you're
watching this brother i don't care if
you like my video
you are you guys are absolute idiots i'm
so sorry yeah
let's find out
i mean those words really help the
palestinian course man
man you are an absolute legend you my
friend need a pedal
i mean such amazing words f all the jews
f them all will send the message by
raping their mothers and daughters
you helped the cause so much my gosh
i don't know how to damn thank you i
don't know should i send you a present
should i wash when i see you shall i
give you a a big fat kiss on your head
what shall i say well you know i'm
really thinking to fathom and understand
that how did you think that is going to
help the damn cause
now it's not even about helping the
cause or not you don't do that period
what is the difference between you and
the far right netanyahu supporters these
zionist scums that are
blowing babies into pieces
literally i saw a video of a father
bombed
he survived his four kids toddlers dead
blown into pieces and his wife dead and
he's crying as he's giving his last hug
to them
this is what i saw today this is how
disturbed i was yeah
and we've got people like you guys in
your cars palestinian flags whoa you
think you're doing something special
f for the jews f their mothers and their
daughters and we'll send a message like
that bravo to
you my friend you come and crap all over
the course
and act like you've done something you
haven't done nothing shame on you
and i'm saying this not because it's
just sabotaging the course
this is against islam number one how
could you insult someone's mom and dad
and we're going to rape them what the
hell are you talking about
what the hell are you talking about zina
is haram what the flipping are you
talking about let alone rape
someone having consensual sex outside of
marriage is
wrong let alone you raping the jewish
mom and a
daughter to send a message are you out
of your mind are you disturbed
and this is enraged me and now
guess what the netanyahu fans
the israeli zionists i'm not talking
about the general jews
yeah the netanyahu and his uh
uh fans his followers zionist scumbags
these dirtbags were dropping bombs on
babies and blowing them into pieces
um so brothers and sisters this is
what's happening and now they've taken
the narrative
so much so people like this ugly patel
pretty patel is
ugly patel that's what her name should
be doesn't talk about
the bombings of the palestinians
doesn't call about doesn't talk about
nearly 100 200 plus people dead
40 kids blown into pieces you scum ugly
patel
you don't see and now you've come and
you're condemning anti-semitism
there's nothing wrong with that the
point is this
what they did is absolutely outrageous
and wrong and we condemn that and we're
not going to let them change this
narrative
of them blowing up kids don't let
anybody change the narrative because of
a group of stupid idiotic
people who have come and tried to
sabotage the course and they're going to
try their best sky news a picture
boris jones is talking about boris jones
is where the flipping hell was you
boris where the hell was you pretty
ugly patel where the flipping hell was
you all the mps that are coming out
and people condemning it should be
condemned the question is this
where the flipping hell was you when
kids are being blown into pieces
you double standard hypocrites you scums
where are you where are you where are
you shh
why because pretty patera ugly patel was
having secret talks with israel
very close to muddy and indians
certainly is not also not all let's get
it right yeah those who support the
hindu foreign flipping hell they're
called this group
yeah muddy supporters the fire right
there as well supporting israel
because anyone that supports israel in a
nutshell if anyone says there's a
conflict happening
in a nutshell they're saying we have no
problem with seeing muslim blood spill
babies blown into pieces no problem that
is what's happening today
and we are not going to let you change
the whole perception
and the whole narrative just because of
a couple of idiotic
individuals who went there shouting and
screaming that's not going to happen
what they did was disgusting
and we are condemning this yeah and i
request all the youtubers muslim
youtubers to condemn and we do we don't
yeah we don't
need to this claire what i'm trying to
say is do not
let them make us forget that a few words
of idiotic people
saying stupid prophetic disgusting stuff
towards jewish people
absolutely wrong okay don't let them
make us forget
that they as we speak are blowing kids
and toddlers into little pieces
this is what they're doing they are
bombing palestinians
do not let them forget that
so this video was a message to these
individuals
uh and uh also to remind you guys
brothers and sisters
that share these videos far and wide
because israel is hurt
and do not be surprised i'm telling you
israel is so hurt they're in a corner
they can come up with anything i would
not surprise with them
trying to force for that attack i would
not be surprised
if some crazy muslim person hamas
comes in does something crazy yeah okay
i would not be surprised
if this happens okay they want to change
the narrative
immediately and do not be surprised if
they come with anything like that until
next time brother sisters assalamu
as wide as you can because as muslims we
condemn what these
individuals said and do not let us
forget that right as we speak and you
watch this now
people in gaza in palestine are being
blown
into pieces bodies over bodies let that
let the whole world
know this inshallah goodbye